d'abord, il se compose d'un matériau en néoprène
qui est idéal pour l'eau - il a une
sangle velcro qui vient à l'arrière de
votre tête ce qui nous permet d'avoir seulement
trois tailles nécessaires petite moyenne et
grande il y a trois trous dans le masque
ou des fentes une sur  la droite et la gauche qui
permettent à l'air de refluer et une sur le devant
qui est une valve de drainage qui permet à l'
eau de sortir du masque
[Musique]
un autre avantage du masque est qu'il est
réutilisable pour réutiliser le masque il suffit de laver
le masque dans de l'eau douce savonneuse  et
laissez sécher vous pouvez réutiliser le masque après l'avoir
utilisé dans toutes les applications telles que l'
eau salée l'eau chlorée toute forme d'
eau est possible de réutiliser le masque
[Musique]
c'est génial vous pouvez respirer même si le
masque est mouillé vous pouvez plonger sous l'eau quand
vous  monter l'eau s'écoule immédiatement
et ça nous permet de nous amuser dans l'
eau
[Musique]